chum in the lakshan was shot by police
on tuesday during a fuel shortage
protest a friend of the 42 year old
father of two explains what he saw
i saw him running after trying to
retrieve his bicycle
then the policeman shot him he fell on
the ground and then i saw the same
policeman chasing people and firing a
senior officer was telling them to keep
firing and they did
lakshan was the family's main
breadwinner his wife priyangani and two
teenage children are in shock
i will be waiting till justice is done
for what happened to my husband i don't
know if that'll happen but it should
someday right
what happened to me mustn't happen to
another person
protesters rallied in rambukhana earlier
this week to condemn the shortage of
fuel and large increases in the price of
essential items
tensions escalated as police attempted
to disperse the crowd a police commander
has admitted giving the order to shoot
casualties were rushed to hospital the
shooting has raised concerns both here
and abroad with the police chief being
summoned before the human rights
commission
a senior buddhist priest at the funeral
condemned the killing
it's because of the wrongful actions of
an extremely immoral and extremely
selfish government that has allowed
lawlessness to reign and that lakshan
lost his life these rulers have no
understanding of good and evil that's
why they've made fraud corruption and
robbery their power and strength
following widespread protests against
the island's worst economic crisis since
independence 74 years ago president
gotaber rajapaksa has reshuffled his
cabinet
choosing a majority of new faces he's
also admitted to making several mistakes
but for more sri lankans it comes too
late
protests are continuing around the
country by thousands of people like
charming the lakshan who had been trying
for days to obtain fuel for his lorry
which he used to make a living
rather than scare people away protesters
say his death will only serve to make
their fight stronger to get the
government to go minil fernandez al
jazeera rambo kana